when it comes to the Netflix original
series stranger things there are a
seemingly endless supply of Easter eggs
and knowing nods to other movies and
pop-culture properties in fact it might
be faster to list all the bits of the
show that don't actually refer to
something else rather than those that do
and that's not all sometimes what looks
like an easter egg
like Lucas's collection of he-man action
figures and Maxine's nickname of Mad Max
are actually just details that come from
a show set in the 1980s but in the
interests of making your next re watch
more satisfying here's a not anywhere
close to complete list of some of the
more overt Easter eggs you might have
missed and stranger things season two
and before you get mad and open up
you're faced with rage like the demo
Gorgon
just remember spoilers ahead sean astin
never says die sean astin who plays
Joyce's doom boyfriend Bob newbie got
his start as an 80s movie icon playing
Mikey in 1985 The Goonies that movie
which feature a group of plucky kids
getting in way over their heads on a
huge adventure is one of the most
obvious sources of inspiration for
stranger things but it's actually one
particular line of dialogue in episode 5
Dig Dug that makes Astin's casting truly
work on a list of easter eggs while
helping Joyce will and Mike try to find
hopper in the maze of tunnels underneath
Hawkins Indiana he jokingly asks about
where the map leads subjective find the
X yeah what's it the X pirate treasure
pop and Goonies as you may recall
revolves around Mikey and his friends
quest to follow a treasure map to find
the lost loot of the pirate one-eyed
Willy
[Music]
all right Willie Matt about Paul Reiser
while he's probably best remembered
these days for his role as Paul Buchman
in the 1990's sitcom mad about you actor
Paul Reiser appeared in stranger things
as doctor Owens he's the new guy running
the lab in Hawkins who's trying to
figure out just what the heck is wrong
with will Byers but back in 1986 Reiser
provided one of movie domes most
memorable bad guy turns and James
Cameron's action sci-fi sequel aliens
he played Burke a two-faced corporate
goon who sends Ripley in the Space
Marines to find more Zeno Morse despite
knowing that they'd all probably die
horribly in the process Owen says
similarly dubious motivations here since
neither Joyce nor the viewers can tell
if the good doctor is really very good
at all
at least on at first we find out by the
end of the season that Owens is more
Buchman than Burke though it costs us a
bob along the way not much luck if your
name begins and ends with a B and
Hawkins huh staying frosty want more
proof that Rises appearance and Hawkins
is a direct nod to aliens among the many
popular franchises stranger things
refers to throughout its second season
aliens might be one of the most
prominent in episode 6 the spy dr. Owens
oversees a group of gun-toting soldiers
who make their way through the tunnels
under Hawkins to try and confront the
shadow monster the kids later refer to
as mind flare he watches on monitors as
the soldiers are ambushed by the demo
dogs who flooded the tunnels that moment
takes its cue from a similar scene in
aliens when Burke and Ripley watched the
Space Marines investigate the alien
infested colony later in the movie
corporal Hicks talks to Hudson and
Vasquez about the need to be on high
alert we're all in strung-out shape but
stay frosty so it wasn't too surprising
to hear one of Owens soldiers say this
towards the end of the episode
alright doremi one of the other major
influences that you can find all over
season two of stranger things is the
movie Evil Dead the 1981 horror classic
by Sam Raimi for starters when eleven is
home alone in hoppers cabin in episode
four will the wise she discovers a
secret door in the floorboards that
leads to a hidden basement that contains
secret knowledge about hopper and her
own past the shots that lead her there
are pretty visually similar to the scene
where Ash and his friends discovered the
Necronomicon in the basement in a
woodland cabin of their own then there's
the abundance of shaky POV cam shots
which is when a camera zooms along the
ground quickly to show the ominous
movements of an evil force Raimi used
that technique to show the point of view
of the evil spirits stalking Ash and his
doomed friends and all three Evil Dead
movies
meanwhile the duffer's bring shaky POV
cam to stranger things when will sees
that now memories of the mine flare
whose tunnelling under Hawkins and
spreading his own brand of evil add the
abundance of creepy vines wrapping
themselves around human bodies to hold
them against their will and the
similarities are impossible to ignore
still somehow not convinced the duffer's
are paying direct tribute to rainy with
season two take a look at this stranger
things promotional poster and then look
at the original Evil Dead movie poster
Raimi should maybe get a co-directing
credit for stranger things season 2 the
Reagan era finally as if throwing aliens
and Evil Dead into a blender with
Goonies weren't enough the duffer's and
the rest of stranger things producers
threw in a healthy dose of The Exorcist
from 1973 for good measure we've got it
all there are young innocents being
subjected to a bunch of pseudo
scientific tests to figure out what's
wrong with them angry mothers demanding
that a bunch of quacks be less terrible
at their jobs and there are possessed
kids being strapped to a bed for their
own good while the demons are being
forced out the only thing that's missing
is projectile vomit no wait that's in
stranger things too
nevermind hail to the king
Matt and Ross duffer the twin brother
creators of stranger things make no
secret of their appreciation for the
works of Stephen King so there are
plenty of subtle and not-so-subtle nods
to the guy whose work inspired so much
of the show for instance Bob tries to
tempt Joyce with the prospect of
relocating your family from Hawkins
Indiana where does he suggest Maine
which just so happens to be the creepy
northeastern state that features
prominently in so much of King's work
then there's the character of xi whose
psychic powers look pretty reminiscent
to those we see in the 1984 king
adaptation firestarter a little girl
violently busting stuff up using only
her mind yep finally there's the secret
knock that hopper uses to let xi know
that he's home a post on den of geeks
points out that if you convert the NOx
to Morse code it translates to the word
it's sure pretty similar to the title of
Stephen King's legendary novel it which
features a group of outcasts friends
banding together to defeat a monster
that's terrorizing their town the fact
that actor Finn wolfhard who plays Mike
on stranger things appears as Richie
Tozier in the 2017 big-screen adaptation
of it it potentially makes hoppers knock
one of the best hidden Easter eggs in
the whole series he's back in Easter Egg
form near the end of episode 4 will the
wise Dustin comes home to spend time
with his rapidly growing pet demon dart
that's when he's shocked to discover
that dart is broken out of his cage and
found a new favorite cuisine
Dustin's cat Mews what could this be a
reference to you guessed it hey Willy
Willy that's right
Alf that wacky puppet from the planet
melmac who had his own sitcom in the
late 1980s and also liked to feast on
felines
[Music]
No then I'll see you in a few days is it
possible that this easter egg is
actually just more of a coincidence than
an intentional one yeah probably but is
it way more fun to imagine that the
duffer's and the rest of their team
spend hours trying to think of a way to
cram an obscure reference to elf into
their hit TV show and that only super
elf nerds would recognize absolutely
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this other cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]